I don't I don't care about traveling
I've travelled way too much I hate
airports I hate it
Nina loves traveling she won't seen the
cities so how do we combine this
I love mean entrepreneurs so let's do
this thing I mean entrepreneurs and then
we have a data goes through the cities
so this whole thing is a combination of
what Nina want to do and now I'm making
it work for my business too involving
the people in your family into your
business and involving her to know what
I'm going through what process and pain
so that when I'm sitting here like
struggling and just like trying to think
of something I'm not in my own world she
kind of gets what's going on but at
least she knows enough about what's
happening in my life so it's not being
completely shut up where's Nina yeah so
so okay so yes for me I need I don't
need to talk about stuff so when I'm
dealing with something I'm an introvert
so I need to go I need to go inside and
figure it out talking about my problems
unless it's us unless as a solution like
I think you can help me I'm gonna talk
to you but if it says something I don't
think he'd help with me just telling you
about it does nothing for me Nina always
wants to know what's happening in my
life and in my day I don't have a need
to tell her but I I have to tell her for
our relationship and so involving the
people in your family into your business
doesn't mean they have to be involved
ever like Nina now quit her job to join
me on this thing that we're doing
together
otherwise she he's not super involved in
what I'm doing day to day she had her
own job but involving her to know what
I'm going through what process and pain
so that when I'm sitting here like
struggling and just like trying to think
of something I'm not in my own world she
kind of gets what's going on so if I
have a youtube issue and I tell her
about it it's like do you want to go
home and like go fix it it's ok we'll
we'll we'll stay and do our thing
together but at least she knows enough
about what's happy in my life so
not being completely shut up so that was
one that made a huge difference just be
able to communicate what's going on to
create a schedule that makes sense for
your life that's why we had that
exercise yesterday so I don't have cell
phone so nobody can reach me like a no
number right it's not buzzing or calling
or anything happening well most people
are baffled it's crazy it's weird that
but but she used to hate that when we
were first together she hated because
she couldn't reach me but now it's great
because when we're together that we can
reach me right and so I think making
sure that you have time that you are
spending together whatever whatever you
need you figure it out
how much time do you need in a week is
it you need time every night you need to
date night once a week do you need like
what makes sense for you guys so for us
we like I work with like crazy every
every moment there shopping at Giant
Eagle whatever down the street and I'm
like DMing people responses right so my
usual routine at home is at 8 o'clock at
work out at night 9 o'clock we'd watch
some show together relax and 10 o'clock
start getting ready for bed so can this
tour it's gonna be nuts but I still want
to find a time every night to be able to
sit still send the couch for an hour and
watch a show just to connect again and
so we didn't do that last night because
we have our crazy event but the night
before we did right it's like we're
preparing it's lost like it's crazy
chaos getting all this stuff ready and
Pittsburgh's the first one so we haven't
fully figured everything out yet and the
year and then all that stuff but ok you
know it's we're gonna take a break we're
gonna watch what do watch a Gotham watch
Gotham for an hour and then went back
and did our thing but it was it was nice
just to like wine down connect Saturday
the whole day is us and I'll plan it so
Nina is planning most of our daily life
stuff but Saturday I plan and I'll find
a new place that she likes her foot I
ain't all had food
I'm a I like food but if it's me I'm
just gonna go eat whatever is kid what's
the closest place
these guys are food aficionados I need
to have like the craziest soup from
three months you know anyway it's like I
don't care about any of that stuff but
I'll plant it because she likes it and
then always some surprise it's not some
big like fancy surprise but let go for a
hike or go to this outlet mall cuz
there's some sale or like whatever just
just the effort that planned the day
we're on Saturday we wake up and she
doesn't know what's happening but it's
gonna be something new and it's not
gonna be work and we don't let the
family admin stuff crouch into our
Saturdays right so Sun is gonna be
groceries and chopping and laundry and
all that stuff right the saturday is our
fun day so that works for us we've got
we've got the evening where we always do
something together and then we got the
whole Saturday where we're doing some
fun stuff and then Sunday we're still
taking care of whatever needs to get
done in the family
does that mean I'll work for you like
maybe we need something more and this is
a bit of Bend
do I like researching all the food
places in Toronto no what are we doing
and she loves soup but I hate soup just
like always having to find soup place
and Danny loves soup - so now we're like
gonna be souped out on this 90-day tour
right so any time it'd be like okay
Saturday we excited is also they will
will cheat on whatever foods and so I
always want like pizza yeah and she
always once soup ramen and fo and you
know say okay so well there's always be
some like wet food soup so I would
research that stuff even though I don't
care about it person I would never do
for myself and then just on how to how
to balance and figure out what you both
need so the thing that we probably fight
the most about our used to would be I'm
very neat and she's very clean so it
bothers me when there's a mess on the
table I have to clean it up like I don't
I can't work in a really dirty not dirty
but like messy office stuff everywhere
yeah I bother
right she can't handle a really dirty
like if there's dirt earth like even if
you can't see it like there's something
she want to mop the floor twenty-five
times not quite but but so I don't mind
I don't mind there's a little crumb
somewhere I'm fine but like stuff
everywhere no as long as it's clean so
so we have to balance that so I'll try
to be more clean for her and she needs
to be a little more neat and tidy for me
and so what do you need right and figure
out the roles so she'll cook the dinner
and then I'll end up cleaning up and
washing up every night she'll wash the
laundry and I'll fold all the laundry
and just finding the balance of what you
both needs it's just a new communication
because it's either argument or America
merry-go-around fight fight fight fight
fight I was like well what do you need
what do I want and then like how do we
make this work together and I think
especially as an entrepreneur there's so
much that we have to go through and
building the business and chaos and it's
an emotional rollercoaster and there's
times where you or it's really difficult
to be committed and do something because
your business is on fire you have to go
deal with this thing I don't know that
we always at least me do a great job of
communicating it so so I've forced
myself like how was your day okay I have
to think about it okay what happened
today I don't know what happened
yesterday what happened I don't remember
I have to force myself to think about it
cuz I'm like I spend zero time look I
don't know how old I am
I wasn't thinking what year it is cuz I
don't even know how old I am right
I don't think back it's always now and
what I'm doing so to think about what
happened yesterday
for for me would be it's like it's
always said what are we talking with
this she needs it so I was like the
great so let's talk about it and then I
think I think what I love most about
Nina and I said yesterday was the just a
support and what I'm doing
she made understand what I'm doing she's
not gonna be the YouTube expert or
algorithm or a that kind of stuff but
she's she'll come with me to do anything
on the tour she's learning how to set up
the lights and take down the lights cuz
Danny's got to do all this crazy stuff
every time we go and she wants to help
and support and then what
what can you do to help on the other
side you know like she had this thing
that she had to submit your idea was
your idea for the HR for the new
workflow or something
remember that graphic that I mean what
was that for yeah the graphic that I
made for your old job what were you
trying to do new policies like new uh
new office rules or whatever and Nina
decided to take this on as her
responsibility great so we're talking
about it so I'm great out of I want to
help like I hate office rules and
policies and corporate rights like the
worst thing of all time it's an
entrepreneur like so brainstorming and
like I came up with half of them and
then I turned it into this graphic this
is this what are they called
infographics you know me number one boom
with a little picture too and but the
logo on on it right
I spend all this time working on this
infographic for her company it's way
overboard of what is needed but then she
shows up the next day and gives it to
them they're like wow this is really
good like can you do more of these
things can we print this off and like
put on the wall and so some kind of
support to to say hey I'm on my dream
I'm trying to do my thing but I know
this is what you're trying to do whether
it's your own business or your hobby
like you love collecting Smurfs great
like I'm gonna start I'll take out a
Google News Alert for Smurfs right
yeah well Gary talks about it it's like
whatever it is right like you love like
Nina used to when we first were dating
she loved little coins that are Canadian
I guess the Americans do it too you have
coins like the quarter might have a
something else in the front yeah for
some occasion right by state or whatever
so any time I came across a calling that
I had something different I'd save it
and give it to her when I when I murder
the next time it's just it's just a
little effort and caring so like what
does she care about the security
whatever okay great so I guess
Bobbo traveling to different colleges
like that's what I'm doing it's our same
thing like I don't I don't care about
traveling I've traveled way too much I
hate airports
I hate it so I was like I'm not gonna I
don't want to travel Nina loves
traveling you want seen the cities so
how do we combine this
I love mean entrepreneurs so let's do
this thing I'm meeting entrepreneurs and
then we have a day that goes to the
cities she loves traveling go get your
trailer your 22-footer
right hitch it up and then go to cities
get your box go do presentations at all
the different colleges across the
country and then you spend the next day
toying around trying food seeing the
city start selling your boxes right like
it's your business you go on the road
right you have your you have a thousand
dollars startup box you're gonna go and
you're gonna sell them out to different
colleges or you have barbers organized
like barbers want to come in and they
want to help remote you or you doing a
Facebook ad campaign and I'm coming here
everybody meet up here and you sell your
boxes it doesn't and it doesn't have to
cost a lot to go right like if you rent
the car or if you have your own car that
you can go with if you're sleeping in a
trailer or if you're if you're renting
Airbnb hotels or you know like you don't
have to you don't have to spend a ton of
capital doing it maybe you've got
friends and family in different cities
look at where you're you're you know
buddies some high school University or
hanging and can I crash at your place
great you got friends in Montana I'm
gonna go to Montana great they're gonna
drive there and then on that way you
look up all of the barber schools along
the way and you do your road show so
this whole thing is a combination what
Nina want to do and now I'm making it
work for my business too if you want to
get coached by me one on one to help you
build your brain and make money as a
thought leader check out my next
workshop in Toronto the link is right
there next to me continue to believe and
I'll see you there